damit kann meine lieben freunde wir
waren gestern auf einer hochzeit
haben wir vielleicht mal insgesamt
gesehen
und ich spiele jeden haben natürlich
vergessen für heute ein video vor zu
produzieren allerdings habe ich jetzt
ein paar coole idee cook auf die straße
so sterben werde dies übrigens die
schlechteste autofahren in deutschland
wie nicht nicht das ist so schlecht
ich habe wie die glorreiche idee
überlegt deine mutter witze vorzulesen
google hat angerufen eine mutter steht
im bild
seine mutter bekommen beim elternabend
einen klassenbuch eintrag
nicht wieder zu beenden deine mutter
schminkt sich mit edding ja das machen
wir sind in luxemburg die hochzeit war
ing auf dieser grenze von frankreich
luxemburg und dem saarland oder
rheinland pfalz
kommt ein schild dass wir in einem
anderen land sind oder so aber den
wichtigen dingen wörter meine mutter
kannte der disco auf die tanzfläche und
schreit dirty dancing
ohne die nicht mein geld deine mutter
ist so fett sie guckt die speisekarte an
und sagt zum kellner okay
[Musik]
lass es doch
eine mutter schüttelt actimel über den
computer mit er gegen viren geschützt
ist das wäre es ein bild ob du
[Musik]
ist echt gut hindenburg und überall
weinfelder die links in die mosel mir
meine mutter arbeitet bei ikea als
unterste schublade
du deine mutter kratzt an bäumen auf der
suche nach hartz iv das ist witzig weil
bäume stoßen arzt aus deine mutter
findet sich ein bobbycar auf den rücken
und ruft transformers
die scheiße aussehen ist wirklich los
seine mutter liz bild beim chatten
das stark
tipp geburt deine mutter arbeitet bei
der losbude als miete
also die sind schon gemein ja deine
mutter piepte wenn sie rückwärts geht
deine mutter hat goethe größe äquators
ist eigentlich alles mein humor aber
irgendwie finde ich richtig witzig wir
können jetzt mit mehr bewerten auf der
skala von 0 bis 10 es geht noch weiter
mit letzten ich habe 50 stücken wie
deine mutter arbeitet bei weight
watchers als vorher bild
ich würde
der sechs von zehn gebe
es auch recht die einzige die wenn die
selber fährt sich festhält sie ist dass
die kamera
deine mutter bringt sogar das happy meal
zum weinen als ich in die box um happy
meal
wir haben heute morgen das frühstück
verpennt und dann kamen wir runter und
die hatten nichts mehr unter standen die
ganze liste der standort actimel der ist
der schatz und ausgepumpt saftlos und
frei auf dem teller graues
schokocroissants lager kuchen aber alles
so halb aufgegessen und wir hatten
nichts mehr da und wir haben auch
gestern abend echt wenig gegessen auf
der neuen seite zweier deswegen ich
verhungern ich könnte dich auf deine
mutter schreck mit ihrem gesicht warum
sagt man eigentlich eher abschrecken das
ist auch wenn die heiß wie kommst du
denn kaltes wasser kurz geparkt oder
erläutert mir das bitte in den
kommentaren nicht wird es mir nicht
durch leben bei der mutter setzt sich in
eine badewanne voll mit verteiler mit
sie auch mal aus der limo winken kann
der starke
wirklich gut deine mutter ist so blöd
wenn sie in einen film ab 18 gehen will
bringt sie 17 freunde mit
benutzt richtig es ist wirklich der ort
ist grafisch und will dort her gefahren
sondern ist wirklich fisch
deine mutter dreht die quadrate bei
tetris das war ja auch mal einfach so
deine mutter geht zu wer wird millionär
und macht schulden
deine mutter ist so fett die bericht vom
stammbaum
denkt sich den schweiß aus das ist genau
mein humor immer wenn ich was schönes
will
schon wieder nur bäume aber kann ich
eigentlich jedem nur empfehlen hier hin
zu fahren wir waren in
[Musik]
ein ausschnitt kater inhalt wenn ich da
rein kommt und methoden ein entweder
oder
die geburtsurkunde deiner mutter war ein
entschuldigungsschreiben von durex
[Musik]
hier immer so ein bisschen was darin
steht klar dass es nur locker an halben
meter über links übrigens
alles voll mit weinbergen ich heiße ich
viel gesoffen wird also da wo ach guck
mal da sind wir schon wieder in
luxemburg in vorne gerade angekommen
wirklich alle fünf meter ist irgendwie
dort schilder werden wird alles offen
hier seien auch gestern also da nicht
hasse halt war eigentlich als weißwein
komplett aber irgendwie stehen hier
überall weinbergen und alle trinken
beinen und ich weiß nicht was dieses
video werfen habt also habt könnt ihr
auch einfach abschalten die
straßenführung hier ist auch ob deine
mutter ist so fett sie hat eine
laufmasche in ihrer jeans was ist eine
laufmasche in der strumpfhose und
russland also niemand aufweisen
[Musik]
jetzt bremst du deine mutter ist auch
deine tante
[Musik]
wir sind wieder den luxemburger
angekommen
[Musik]
keine mutter setzt beim online poker
eine sonnenbrille augen
recht einfach nicht wenn sich eine
mutter trug zur hochzeit eine burger
king krone ach guck mal
das könnte ich immer wichtig sein
das bild jedoch auf meiner hochzeit
berger haben oder
[Musik]
seine mutter zieht flip flops mit einem
schuhlöffel an
komme dass dies auch falsch dass wir
gestern schon der gefangenen auch eine
ganz große empfehlung von uns hier
dieses bistro dieses letzten rang man
kann hier super schön auf die moose
gucken die jedoch nicht seht ich hoffe
mal dass die mosel ist aber so sieht das
restaurant auf jeden fall aus heißt wo
die ral und ich habe keine ahnung aber
diesen tieren
[Musik]
88 deine mutter wirft einen stein auf
den boden und trifft mächtiger und
bestellt sich gleich zwei mal all you
can eat wer hat denn diese langeweile
sich so was wahrscheinlich so leicht wie
der katalog ist deine mutter ist so dumm
wie schaut sich bei youtube tutorials
fürs brot schneiden an
das ist genauso wie verletzten video
gesehen das hat die millionen von
aufrufen autobauer water also wie man
wasser elst
jetzt war plötzlich in deutschland
angekommen echt wild deine mutter schaut
bei einer glastür durchs schlüsselloch
die glastür hat doch gar kein schnitzel
oder
schlecht ist
nicht
deine mutter welt wenn es an der tür
klingelt
deine mutter steckt sich nehmen sie
angehört
wir lassen das betet für mich dass ich
nicht sterbe auf der autofahrt